you didn't don't see us on a shrink
takes a second okay it's not that fast
there's checking you sure yeah we should
be should be there all right three two
one all right and we are laughs the last
word with a Bartis how's it going on sir
that's pretty good got up headin get
breakfast this morning got a workout in
start off ready right you know not too
shabby
got a yeah get the workout in trying to
try to get ready for Guardian Kong you
know you know hang out at the pool with
the wife so whoo gotta look like I you
know there's not enough time you know to
be like hey I'm beast mode it's just
like hey I don't look like total trash
so you got a dad bod the situation I'm
trying to be less trying to be less I
respect that about two weeks and I got
III coming up so I got a gig I gotta get
my Kelly bar ready I'm just gonna be
I'll be running to work every day
where's about 20 miles away I got I got
some changes to make so I get some
recovery to go so yeah that going on
this morning and then breakfast was I
got there it was the kodiak pancake or
whatever I got the got that one my wife
was like what about blueberry pancakes I
was like all right let's put them
together protein blueberry pancakes oh
yeah it's not a bad start to the morning
so we'll see how hungry I am in like one
hour
hopefully the car kicks actually the
protein holds over that's was so bad you
must be busy man obviously we play some
cop we got some gaming in so that was
good
just about that I know you do I know you
do because you do a lot of cop oh it's
such a slow mowing to build there bend
deer in the building dramatic but fuel
81 we have love saying that name and of
course the WD Prescott what's going on
Forte you're not even see Forte
but the green fun everybody's in here
that's what's up man yeah but there's a
lot of complicating that going on
putting up some articles for Lords a
game in that net I mean my III bag right
now I'm in my entry bag
want to talk about that later to remind
me as we go through the 12 because on I
think they may be alluding things oh
yeah yeah yes so we got to talk about
that yeah and Sam but now they're not
been good man just saw in the grind
getting ready
III is probably the busiest time for B
so just preppin and everything that
comes with it but once it's all done
back asleep of course was like yeah I
get up early and try to get my workout
in and made a little quick video this
morning and then jump in make breakfast
and you're like somehow there's not
enough time to do this have fun and
things like that it's weird so before we
get going I did want to just shout out
something for everybody
before I even talk about comp or
anything I've seen other people talk
about this and then I saw a Grenadier
Jake's video I don't know if you saw
that one you know so it's one of those
things about being a content creator and
I'm not complaining right now cuz it's
not like my full-time thing but it's one
of those things I've seen from somebody
else and this also goes to creating
content to also those creating games and
sorry to anybody for watching stream
this morning I'm sorry if there any dips
hopefully it's not too bad
but if you watch any content creator out
there anybody you get to be a big fan of
anything like that just know that
they're human like you are X people get
burnout people have different things and
it happens in any job as well so there
are certain things when somebody gets on
and they stream like you know eight
hours a day it's a job but for some
people they may have like gotten into
something maybe they're an introvert or
something and doing that eight hours a
day is an absolute wreck on them
alternately but they don't show it so
it's just one of those things when it
comes to hearing about crunching game
developers and hearing about like
streamers and stuff getting burnt out
and then it's it's a tough thing to find
a balance and the ones who are lucky
enough to be like hey I'm born for this
I'm crazy outgoing having fun making
lots of money and it's like the people
who are yeah it's just one of those
things I've seen a little bit and I see
I see little things all over the place
and people have like usually pretty
solid reactions I also saw a Grenadier
do
look at the twitch later and chat was
just like love across the board and
there's usually some things but there's
the I came to the moment of toxicity and
it just seems so out of place in there
and I don't get it and the same thing
when you have and that's why the reason
I'm bringing this up mostly is because
of the nerfs isn't because the same
thing it's like you may have opinions
you may not like them but the way you
handle yourself whether it's on the
internet whether it's in person whether
it's on iphone needs to be as a
respectful human being absolutely
absolutely I mean no I was just gonna
say and just like some of the stuff over
the the stupid lie there threats or like
hey I'm just gonna quit your game or all
the stuff it's like they have reasons
for doing stuff worried whether you
agree or not that's totally fine yeah
but just the times when they get to be
over-the-top and not necessary or giving
people a hard time or wondering what's
happened with this ke8 and they let me
remember they're they're humans they're
just people like you are if they gotta
take little breaks if they gotta do
different things
just be decent so that's all I just
wanted to get out there just with all
the craziness going on lately I feel
like I have to say this every so often
if you're not having fun go find some
way to have fun cuz it's just yeah go
ahead but I just wanted to get that out
there after a couple things that I'd
seen cannabis really that's real talk
the thing is it's like I've seen a
toxicity you know and the way I look at
it is just like look man at the end of
the day you got a decision to make
alright as a content creator you have a
decision to make in reference to burnout
and stuff like that I go through it you
don't mean like I'm we just talked about
you know I'm doing a lot and sometimes
you know you get a little frustrated you
know saying and you got I think my main
motto is appreciate what you do have
because people ain't got listen to me at
all you know films like alright you know
so that's the first thing so yeah you
may not be where you want to be and
that's it's hard sometimes I know
especially with how hard a lot of us
guys work I know how hard you work you
know same thing and I know I'm putting
it in so that's the first thing you know
be appreciative little dude in the
second thing to the second point what
you said which is in reference to the
toxicity I think is one of the things
where I was like look I'm from the
school where I don't never want to talk
disrespectfully I want to be able to say
what I can say if that person was
literally
fun of me you shouldn't say so that
because there's a different energy right
is the different energy like anonymity
of the internet exactly because there's
a lot of dudes doing this and that's
cool that's cute you can say what you
want just be respectful that's all I say
just be respectful because the end of
day it's still a human being at the
other end it's angry as I get with this
caves or doves
do you go B I go about [ __ ] of
rennes oh but I'm passionate about by
the end of the day it's a job and I got
a decision to say you know what I don't
want to play anymore because I'm just
and that's it but I think it's the
people who go on grandstanding that's
certain and you know that this person at
and you know degen acting it'll say and
it's like that just to disrespect let's
just just be cool just because again if
that person was in your face would you
have that same kind of energy and that
whole entitled bit and if the game is
BOTS we'd have much guess what there's
other games you can play enjoy that's
your fail you see liner so you so
district so upset it is so angry at the
direction is they nerf that skull of
diamond because so much you know what
there's the visit to it is boy lads come
in you know you can like I said what
with your wallet and do all this up
stuff so that's all I got it but good
point I'm glad you brought that up
that's actually a fantastic point so
yeah there take a breath occasionally
and and just remember to if you do have
an opinion like constructive criticism
formed with like thought incoherent
opinions yes II will always go a hundred
times farther than being just a jerk on
the internet and yelling and screaming
and throwing a tantrum temper tantrum
not gonna it's yeah doesn't do any good
and doesn't get the point across and
remember it's like two things a whole
lot of people don't do they a lot of
people don't listen for one yeah they
don't act they they wait to talk they
don't actually listen to understand
these difference a lot of people to
those huge and then to it's like if you
actually wait and think and you take
that second be like put yourself in
somebody else's shoes put yourself in
the developer shoes and be like okay so
they're going through these changes one
nurse oh I really love whisper and stuff
like that we'll try and think through
why would they be changing this stuff
what is going on I mean and you can have
opinions that say hey maybe their boss
design what the slams isn't the best
thing it'd be like hey you know if this
is kind of a design maybe it's a design
mechanic things just find your way to
like have a coherent argument right like
have a like a thought process of maybe
that doesn't work why does it not work
and go through and go through the whole
process don't be like that doesn't
doesn't help anything so that was just I
wanted to get out there in the beginning
because watching his video by the way I
mean shout out to him
like he used to do trials carries and
stuff like that and he was just talking
about his like journey he's gone through
and just debating on taking a break from
all this stuff and it's it takes it on
some people so it's one of those for him
and it was emotional each I'm not even
again he told my leaving the game like
leave it streaming and stuff for a
stream in a game in a stuff for a while
and he's I mean that's one of those for
him he's like hey it's been cool it's
been kind of tracking down tried some
other things but he's just getting to a
point to where I'm for him it's
affecting personal life yeah that's when
when you cross that line and it's now
becoming unfun and affecting your
personal life yeah then you've really
got some decisions you gotta wait yeah
so that just just remember everybody
behind these pieces of text or humans
and there's probably even more people
behind them as well whether it's a
spouse whether it's you know 800
developers behind the people right in
the club all those people who are
killing themselves making amazing art or
sound effects or missions or all those
things there's always so many poor
people out there that are involved in
this stuff so just take a second
remember that I know this is all like
preaching and stuff in the beginning I'm
sorry just turn it out there to start it
out just being behind brother turn the
ship a little bit here so respect what
even let's talk about some destiny to I
know we've been playing actually played
with you a little bit this week most
people a together well so what have you
been what are you working on right now
cuz it's a time where we know these of
opulence is around the corner we'll talk
about that in a minute but you have that
like kind of downtime we see we can I
didn't we've got what we're gonna get
for this season so what's here what's
your grind and then I'll talk about mine
what do you what did it give for me it's
like I've always get it like I always
get into like this what I call the pre
BL
Simo right well you're like two weeks
out I call I get two weeks out he does
they're like before a fight so when you
before the fight you're trying to prep
as much as you can for all the
adjustment see I'm a person yeah I may
complain when the nerves come out and
like oh I don't like this or whatever
whatever but at the same time I adapt so
the way I look at it it doesn't matter
what meta bungees gonna do I'm gonna be
ready you're nothing
so when you know scouts or in you know
the trash right now
I'm holding on to some of the best roles
I got in my fault you did when this is
going on this gets nerfed in in um in
crucible of PvP I have my options so I
think for me the number one thing is
shout out you know I know pretty much a
lot of you guys may know already but
what's the whispered joint hit I'm like
okay I really need to focus on the next
best thing in my repertoire which would
be Darcy right so I'm like all right let
me get Darcy out lo and behold I'm like
oh I had the catalyst I didn't realize
it so I'm like alright let's get it
going so I'm like running triple sniper
China you know get the kills cuz long as
you have Darcy equipped you get crazy
so rockin that Shea and I'm actually I
learned some stuff I learned um
escalation protocols Piper is really
good yo use that that's been sitting in
my vault forever I've never used it it
literally I dusted it off I'm like y'all
box breathing triple tap good Amos is a
heavy arm ammo count like oh this is a
nice little I'm literally running like
almost either two snipers and and blast
furnace or whatever three snipers just
getting the kills trying to get that
catalyst on because I want that maximize
so that's the first thing in their PvP
op sees where I saw it you cuz obviously
I am the cop guy love to get comp turn
login one morning I see this ebon chest
character playing crucible what's this
since that's your vest did you like yeah
let's get it so we just got it in man
and shot the box is carrying me this
whole week he's out here put me the
backpack show me how comp is played he's
humble he's putting in work y'all don't
get me wrong like I haven't played PvP
in a while no excuses
a bill that I don't like but I'm trying
to get this confident but not tighten up
he's got his he's got his ace of spades
yeah I'll hear moving you know this so
I'm just following his lead try to get
these wins and get these solar kills for
Luna get that out the way recluse
working on at the same time and it was
one other thing I've got one of those um
what a mother crucible bounties I think
at the same time think what is it the
one we have the the grenade launcher one
that's annoying yeah yeah so I figured
you know what why not just you know
throw that bad boy and get it done
on three what about you
well basically at this point I've got I
was like okay so I started knocking
things out somewhat recently been
working on seals cuz those are it was
like okay I can grind some of those out
I'm a wheat next weekend we gonna get my
curse breaker so I'm one week away from
now which is kind of cool so just wait
on this do you have sir well I got
dredging Fergie's that one happened I
was playing a shot at the bender and
having those guys playing with that
night we got the four stack to get the
75 motes deposited without losing any so
that's the one where you got it if you
get that one luckily you are lucky cuz
yeah we coordinated the crap out of that
one first
then I got wayfarer which took the grind
of just pretty much everything everyone
played curse of Osiris so I had that set
and I forget I was talking to somebody
didn't have that one mm-hmm but I was
waiting on Mars to drop me like one
weapon mm-hm and it's from doing all
those little memories fragments or the
little things yeah little tiny diamonds
that like open the hole and then they
closed like um like to simulate sleeper
nodes or whatever they're called yeah no
okay so I had to do those like and you
and it's just like the way the would you
want to go grind some of that stuff I
would you see questionable nature in
ways some of that stuff is built yeah
because like you can do four of those
like three four five somewhere in there
you'll get a drop at some point and it's
the what is it the Mars schematic or
whatever brate xq mattock and you can go
get wonder up but that's it
for the day you have to wait and
sometimes it's like some little time
gated stuff you're like it's not quite
the best feel yeah yeah I agree and
funny you said it's to catch jump in I
actually started curse of Osiris to get
it done and um I noticed that two like
that remember the whole thing when
you're doing the prophecies and you got
the tablet and then they what you do
public events and everything is kind of
like I just didn't like the progression
and I see why curse got the the flack it
got like it's a lot of the progression
those weapons uh-huh rough man that's
rough man
it is rough yeah I got that so finally
had that one drop and then and I was
waiting on I think that was one of my
last pieces when that one dropped a fit
and then it was like the weekly cycle
for actual escalation protocol so that
happened so that was way fair and then I
was like all right so I got my wish
under what's going through suiting eggs
on the ascendant challenges so that's
next week and I was like what about
chronicler and I'm going to video
recently and you can actually just put
up a video about the lore book for verax
as well yes because that one is one that
is like you can only work on those at
specific times like the ghost stories
you can run around go get all the
collectables
you know some are just done by playing
the campaigns but then seeing the
chroniclers like truth to power
specifically is the one that's like only
on cursed Week three can you get that
progress done and I was like every time
traffic yeah I'm gonna finish my four
days before that little pin goes off
sale but I think I'll be able to get
four pins I'm not I'm not going for like
the whole reign flawless on either of a
scourge life that perfect Indiana Jones
Sparrow run you're not about that life
yep that's a much so yeah all that
happened and then I was like all right
what else cuz I kind of know I'm at the
point where I just have to wait I was
like what else can I work on and I was
like crucible weapons yeah so I jumped
into and honestly what prompted me off
and like dang it Bungie for doing it
with the invitation having to actually
play comp
mm-hmm that was what it was so
it was like so I did the two or the
three Rumble matches that kind of quick
play and then I played cop and I was
like I won two out of three and I was
like I had like 348 glory it was just
like from randomly playing at some point
and then I got like two out of three and
I was like I went back after that was
done was like yeah let's go see what
some matches like we don't like a streak
had like five or six wins in a row and
all of a sudden I was like I'm like half
way to 2100 halfway to Fable I was like
okay hold on hold up before I lose any
more so shout out to Carolina gamer he's
got the he's got Pete he's got help he's
got a discord server out there he's like
helping people you know putting him in
their backpack basically so I went in
there ended up playing with one guy on
that server who was cool we got about
part wait there they didn't finish him
with his team and got there so I was
like cool I got fabled so I got Rekluse
and then I was like well what else
mmm Luna's hell oh my god that grind
shoutout to anybody who's done it and by
anybody's mean who has the not forgotten
that is a long long grind because it's a
hand cannon kills 200 solar kills which
is sometimes more specific than you
think
well matches was like and then now I'm
on the hundred precision kills and I
have ten to go oh man you big look at
you in my blade Oh like slaves so much
comp in the pipe laid more comp in the
past week than probably my entire life
of destiny I know it's weird to see you
exclusively like I'm like what is he
doing in my era this is weird and going
hard like you are going hard in this
thing living in there just absolutely
living in combat I gotta ask you to
question cuz I know you're grinding
right but part of me thinks you enjoyed
himself a little bit against it I seed
like I seen the fever star you like did
you get you call-outs I'm like okay he's
getting mid to this because now you're
understanding what I like I mean is it
perfect no but it's something about
Destiny's PvP like it still has a hook
now grander I know how you feel about
County ain't gonna talk about contact
not
no [ __ ] yeah so countdowns the game-mode
that I have strong opinions on and the
only one when half the people that have
played with her like Oh countdown like I
have a hunch if you could vote even I
don't care the map if you could vote the
game-mode that you play yeah before you
start the match say it's between like
its - its control or countdown or
clashing countdown or survival and
countdown and I've got to feel like
nobody's gonna be picking countdown
honestly because my issue with countdown
is the way you design a game-mode to try
and detonate this chart right that's
your intended goal the way it's played
at a higher level is they just go for
the kills they don't get over the charge
because if you get the charge and unless
you can defend it it's hard to defend it
than it is to just go wipe out the other
team there's wipe out the other team
right so fundamentally it's not always
to your advantage to do the objective
it's you can seems like if you go like
dunk early and you're just waiting for
one year split they're probably four and
three then they might take your team
then just wipe you out and come back and
to just turn it off and it's just like
and they have enough time it always
sounds like they're not gonna have
enough time they seem to always have a
pretty good amount of time to get that
thing uncharged or whatever so countdown
I have opinion mm-hmm
for status for stacks against the solo
man over here who's that
me I'm a solo guy in pop like and with
it if you like pair up and you're like
all these people have the same emblem oh
I know it's a four oh god here we go
again
it's a it's a very different feel I mean
it really is because it'll be like hey
one person's going around and flanking
hey you can tell when they're like kind
of team shot all coordinated
oh yeah because you're like I could just
get one more shot but then they try it
out they literally just like shift
positions with somebody aatul health and
I'm like God so many times I'm I'm like
the king you might be the cool you might
be like the prince or whatever but dude
I am the king of wounding but not
killing Oh save that the hunters and
maybe they just roll away then they out
like oh I don't have backup I don't have
backup dodge as a Titan late mm-hmm
I mean okay I wanna sirs are built for
PvP and they know absolutely this that
the did triple jumping in the its man
have been like over jump time like like
Oteri's is the Mindbenders ambition to
thing is this so yeah either be in like
so like my skill level not great I might
be able to so look you up to 2100 but I
seem to hover 1800 1900 2000 somewhere
there's some like I'm okay but I'm
definitely like no in hell I'm gonna get
up to not forgotten for what on my own
cuz that's just not gonna happen and to
stuff yeah so but no I'm actually like
I'm enjoying certain pieces of it I like
the feel of its kind of a more a little
more coordinated working together you
see people in comp actually like most
people are gonna be in there cuz I went
to go play rumblin I saw dude like just
like with a but I did not see Wiley
that wasn't Rumble he's just getting his
games in or whatever but in in Cup I
don't see that at all so people do take
it a little more a little more seriously
you don't have to be crazy die-hard but
people are like people are trying
they're like coordinator on the like
heavy MLB like a pop and shields they
may not always take the heavy if they're
not built for it on all run all right
it's a different feel it's talking on
like my bed the reason why I love it is
much not saying I'm doing the great as
either I'm like average above average
you know the best day but the thing I
reason why I like it is that I learn the
true Matt I learned what's really
effective because there's some things
that I call cute mean quick play like
you leo that's cute you got all you get
like a 23 key oh this is my gun this is
my loadout you bring that bad boy up in
a comp you get to see how ineffective
that loadout is so I'm like okay like
literally when I'm playing with you
I was sitting a the team I was playing
one because I was in my counter outbreak
prime loadout yeah when I started when I
play with you this week and nobody was
running prawns that much shared a lot of
them I see it that so this week I didn't
see it and it was different loadouts I
had to deal with it I was dealing with a
lot of shotgun eggs come I was
completely unprepared and I was dealing
with more lunes and I'm like okay got it
though visit us a little bit away now I
got a throw all my escalation little way
so what I did is I got the new joint
where I did um I got my bug out my 940
which calls to rushes and I brought back
out last word which I actually can use
and I was playing more effective as we
got on a little bit better them sinks
when we first started I had my old
vigilance I had other lineups I was
messing with trial Malfi so tried a
couple things I just wasn't in my groove
with the competition now it's facing
that with this week with you but um yeah
man I that's why I like it it's to me
just more about information what's
effective what's not effective and um
just being able to adjust on the fly to
what people are doing but I will say
this I cannot wait to do so little kills
over cuz I hate using shots of people
who could use don't play super I'm just
not that good with it man I mean I'm not
you know what it's you know why I don't
like it it's a good super but because he
holds the sword it blocks my view of
like I have to be in the air all the
time so I can get a hover or to see
everybody at you know around you but you
can't really do that in a lot of these
enclosed maps you said I'm saying so for
me I rather much you know about you that
I even rather use phone call at this
point right now it's something about the
way dawn blade is when you using it it
obstructs my view to actually lash out
at the enemy and I actually get killed
more sometimes because of it unless I'm
in the air so that that's just me just I
mean I will say dawn blade so yeah
opinions about supers mm-hmm
me I run Titan now I will 100% agree
one-eyed mask crazy crazy advantage it
advantageous so watching the tag waiting
for him to peek in and out and stuff
like that definitely helps a lot no
question not arguing that is but when
you are facing off against hunters
spectra blades that I can throw at
height a hammer at and it just like it
bounces off of them like I'll go super
I'll smash them in the face
they seem to be fine and they don't even
die from the hammer and the explosions
they swipe me and just keep going and
keep moving and keep moving they can
cover so much ground trying to think of
another like couple of the ones that
have lasted so long
Don blade last a long-ass time by the
way it does it does it does I'm not
gonna say it does I'm not gonna say it's
probably just me I just don't like how
it obstructs my view and I'm saying that
what it would deal with the way the
swords in a way but the super itself is
effective it's copy no thing oh but now
I need my Nova warp and I named stone
call I can't wait to finish these solar
kills and be done with it so I can play
my normal PvP sup glass and then blade
brush oh oh my panic panic no aim on
screen not like panic Thunder Thunder
crashing gonna be near him right so I
understand like you got to be near them
they might pop here on the corner I'm
like fine that's like a no well except
it there's only so much you can do but
like halfway across the map I'm gonna
panic up in front I can literally throw
a hammer and have it like releasing out
of my hands but this far if not hitting
a guy if he thomas blade brush he
survives kills me in my super and he
still does it and then he survives and
I'm dead and I'm like ultimate it's the
ultimate shutdown super I'm over it to
be honest I trust I'm not saying you're
wrong it's just like so used to it now
it's like it's just it's one of those
that like sometimes the super balancing
does it they don't feel remotely even to
me because like I mean so I like
everybody's like I mean Golden Gun is
probably still gonna be able to shut me
down to where I'm Nova bomb that one's
slow it's really hard to get away from
but it'll still really kill you as well
it's like that slow death of like no no
no no no you know what you can do but
it's really like my hand I feel like
hammers and I could be the only one just
cuz I'm the dumb guy playing Titan in
PvP but like if I throw a hammer in it
is
direct contact yeah that should kill you
or at least trade like I'll do some
trades but that should and a lot of the
supers they survive and I'm just like
what the hell yeah no I agree if you're
super named supering someone else you
should like that should be cuz if they
get me I should be able to get them like
that seems like a fair trade because I
at least have to aim mine especially if
they're far away
exactly and like I said that armor and
spectral braids aggressiveness is it
tough it's a tough one so that one's
coming though right that we've got that
that nerf we'll see yeah so but honestly
what I will say is I know company
frustrated a lot of people it may not be
your bag and it's one I've played a lot
more and I was kind of like I always
play destiny pvp Emily not as terrible
as it I'm not great you're actually
solid man you don't give up okay I'm
like why doesn't he play more like you
solid like you have an idea of what
you're doing but I will say like fur
comp it will change quickly can be like
hey I'll just run in I'll do this stupid
stuff like it will change it will get
will make you understand the value of
each one of your lives
mm-hmm staying alive whether it's
survival whether it's countdown ball
whatever it is like when you hit an
engagement it's like and that's where
hunters are really crucial at this is
they get the dodge back out but it's
that point where you get tagged but not
killed or you play smart and you're like
I gotta go like I got I got ting but I
didn't get killed I gotta be like I got
a duck I'm gonna go a different
direction regain health while I take a
different path as opposed to I'm just
gonna force this one cuz I really don't
care
those little thought processes will make
you a better player takes time and
believe me my week has been really slow
progress but it's just the mentality of
like win to win does actually go for it
if you think you can or when you think
when you know you're gonna be beat and
you can't save it and if those little
pieces that make a lot of difference
actually so it makes you a better player
for sure
and then my final piece is I've been
using ASA spades like crazy I'm on PC so
that seems to be a good way to go and
it's been hand cane as the whole time so
why not but I will definitely say you
get a huge like you
know when you're on the host side and
when you're not yeah it's so obvious I'm
like man I'm like nailing these Ace of
Spades shots next time I'm like I cannot
hit what feels like the broadside of a
barn he's like what is and they're just
completely different feels and I'm like
I'm the same guy shooting the guy I know
my skills not doing like a moment but my
skill is no way up here like I'm hitting
everything going on like a five or six
streak momentum or is just locked in the
entire time - I can't hit a dude in the
chest or the shoulder or the toe much
less the head and it's those feelings of
leg at all it appears so yeah
chalk up the another one definitely in
the dedicated service column - no well
hopefully not at they're free from
Activision and we know how activation
doesn't like to do dedicated servers but
their honor that's gonna cost them their
own money so yeah that was a really long
talk about cops sorry I know you guys
probably came here to talk about season
Bob you lence but yeah so honestly like
I'm enjoying what I've been doing it's
kind of an interesting way to play it
makes me kind of appreciate for one the
skill of others because sanely good to
watch what the epic ones can do and then
to just to be lit just to think about
things a little different a little
smarter so I know come visit my
everybody but I have been I've been
enjoyed it so honestly like whatever the
next pinnacle is I might I might
actively triangle after a bit more so
that's what I'm talking about is like
he's got that value what value a to stay
a while like VI I still love doing even
if I'm not playing well like I'm
learning I'm getting information and
then you get that that satisfaction when
you get those weapons bad you feel good
you know you grinded to get said weapons
enough about comp yeah it's mean all
right so comp talk done mmm
Bob 12 times so everybody's been
anticipating this and then what comes
next in the tois because guess what
we're gonna be talking about season of
opulence and next week actually thinks
the Kosmos tweet is going to be probably
even more
like what people are waiting for mostly
because he's gonna be talking about the
stuff everybody wants Pinnacle weapons
sandbox buffs and more season of
opulence endo that's next week
that's gonna be a fun table that's gonna
be a fun swab yeah pinnacles are always
cool so let's get a little forecast what
do you think
since now we've got gambit Vanguard and
crucible give me archetype what do you
think hit me
mmm comp let's see um we let's go let's
just backtrack for a second because we
got the last one we've got recluse right
we're close they do not learn is not
forgotten
yeah yeah I think we do probably don't
for pulse mate because rhetoric see so
maybe I go first
yeah put Roger to the first I'm trying
to think of the archetype that we
haven't touched yet scout scout scout
I mean scout sniper shaadi right okay
those are pretty sure at comp shotty now
these would be the one actually a couple
of people asked about two instead of a
bed it's gonna be sniper or scout I say
Scout because they so underutilized and
I think Bungie wants to because I think
of having bow off kpop Oh little side
bar when you're playing in comp around
2100 and there's two people on the other
team
mostly exclusively using bows fear them
by the way yeah no no lame monarch and
then I think what's the other one
try to remember what they were hitting
me with either way if somebody's
exclusively using a bow and comp they
know how to use that bow and cup and
it's impressive
so anyway mark I'm gonna go with my
guess I'll go with Scout just cuz 1g I'm
gonna guess they want to get some
archetypes usage up what you going with
well the underdog story would be a
sidearm oh Lord
[Laughter]
yeah bad they're not that bad it was
like I mean they took a submachine gun
like reclusa made it pretty made it like
yeah liable everywhere so it's all about
what it does you know not a lot of
people love sidearms but if they could
lock it in make it really solid and
stable maybe give it a cool perk like
that could but I was like they just hit
that range with some machine guns so I
feel like the farther range is gonna be
one to think about which is kind of
annoying because the more you play PvP
the more you see some maps like the one
that used to be the one with the three
lanes it's a big sniper map Oh a big
sniper one the other is like outside
inside middle mostly like middle and
inside nobody plays the outside on them
nobody plays the outside in d2 I noticed
that no one goes outside I used to but
they used to yeah you know but like so
sniper would have some uses scout would
be interesting because they try to scout
and Vanguard and it's May yeah so we've
got yeah I'd be curious to see sniper
what they would do to make a comp sniper
specific so mmm Vanguard what do you
think there hmm
we had oxygen we've had loaded question
yeah what else we had those are only two
I feel like I think I started the
pinnacles in comp right yeah first I
think yeah Vanguard was late and then
game bit was just this one I think yeah
so we got scout we got yeah we do for
another archetype I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say hey I can pep let's get it
back a PG hand cannon would be a rocket
launcher that's about the only thing
that would be nice
a rocket with like what if it had two in
the clip mmm so two tailed fox or just
like two without having to reload
without being without yeah kind of be
interesting just bring back bring back
the rocket launchers gambit I have no
idea what they're gonna do because after
21% delirium don't know 20 million we
had um breakneck
yeah yeah so
yeah yeah I don't know it's like they
they're gonna start stacking on top so
it'd be curious what they're how
creative they've got a ton of archetypes
that they just haven't touched because
the Met is for those archetypes suck so
what I I think it's gonna be a my guess
is it'll be archetypes that have not
been used before but what they'll do is
they'll coincide it with a balance
update to that entire weapon class yeah
because if you remember when Rekluse
dropped smg's got a slight buff overall
yeah so that's how they tend to marry
this on Bungie logic that's ongoing but
you know I think that they might do it
dramatically bring 40 well yeah let's
see let's say you have that day I think
it'll be a class that if theoretically
is weak but they'll put something new in
that archetype buff the archetype as a
whole and then maybe we get some special
to happen like we can't run close it's
gonna be I think it's gonna have to be
better than or close to cuz we're close
now
heard that like short to mid yeah Astrid
arm procs I'm still getting used to
actually like thinking about it right
now but it is powerful when you see it
it's just like oh I'm not doing that
damage master arms like mmm just mode
that health bar down well and being
killed by over and over and over over
yeah that should be interesting so
that's coming next week the pinnacles
will be a discussion sandbox buffs so
some will be coming just as you said
probably coinciding with some of those
pinnacle weapons that makes pretty
perfect sense for sure and the more
seasonal opulence info but this week we
got some info more about day one a lot
of it just so we kind of know what's
coming so from one season to the next as
season different comes to a close a new
source for powerful rewards will emerge
so this time The Drifter will return to
his role of gambit hype man and Benedict
is about to become your source for brand
new secrets and rewards so Benedict 99 -
40 I wish he had a little closer walk to
get to because he doesn't he's not easy
no matter which way you come from so yep
I'd like him to move to another spot
Matt cave bunker down the stairs around
the corner so our search bounties that
we're at The Drifter will actually be
changing so instead of a set of bounties
a new power surge quest will be jumping
you'll be our jumping-off point for
season of opulence this is the key
number one you will need to complete
this quest to access the raid don't doom
learning from seasonal forge this quest
must only be completed once per account
thank you we like that we like after one
character complete the quest alternate
characters will be reward with surge
gear at power level 690 so first taking
1 season to learn and what do you think
I'm sorry to repeat that last taking one
season and just learning how they're
rolling out the power surge this time
mmm cool I'm okay with it I mean they're
making this a prerequisite to the REA
cool you know I'm gonna reissue with it
um to me this is just more so as we'll
get into the next series with Gary buddy
I think they're just trying to add more
importance to Benedict and um you know
it's interesting that they're making
this you just can't like just go you
have to do this part so I'm very curious
to see what this quest will entail would
it be something simple like invitation
than mine kind of stuff you know I'm
saying or you know whether it be like
story down is be some story doubt it but
let's give us some story dollar right
come on come on yeah we had a strike you
know I can't remember me asking for a
strike a story mission at this place
Yves Vee
I got a story mission through previous
content like they did the adventure
unnecessarily vayan I can see them do
some stuff like maybe some callus over
or something like that to get us in that
direction to like kick off the season
because this is how you're gonna start
and then if this is your requirement to
go on the raid it has to connect
otherwise I'll be discipline it it
should I will say it should connect II I
know this is the annual pass nor this is
also Vicarious Visions
swansong has had the longest to be
developed so I'm hoping at least if you
have a quest that is required for the
raid it connects to it if it doesn't
that is a lost opportunity I'll just say
that I would agree with you okay I'm
trying to keep it trying to keep a
decent here remind you we're coming off
just walking up to a later tower
remember that we had a DES
we had the forges we had the broken
Niobe labs which was you know stuff
happens then we had the invitations of
the nine getting some I feel like
they're setting up so I was actually
sorry
side bar again the last invitation of
the nine did you watch it I did not okay
do you know what happens in it you can
spoil okay I did I did I think by put
something up he probably did but is it
goes yeah you can go for it you can go
for it
so basically we've got the drifter
talking to the emissary I'm kind of as
to what's going on and he has shout at
the name last night he was kind of on
DCP I was that awesome one talking about
it basically saying like the drifter
fears actual combat that's why sends us
to do all these different things but
he's having these dreams and visions of
another collapse of another like over
take of the darkness that's like that's
what he's fearing so his little coin
that he flips the as it always changes
to scorn or high or whatever it's gonna
be this is the first time not the first
time they've acknowledged but you have
Mars home like throne world that has the
triangle ships and they're now on his
coin it's a triangle ship mmm that's the
icon it's not hive not score and he
flips it looks down and she's and she's
like he's like I've been worried about
what's coming and stuff like that he
looks down and it's on there so like
this is all like some preamble and lore
building and I swear they're setting
this up because
to me mm-hmm
if they bring the space and this is
again where we're gonna see what comes
in the future when we get the later
stuff like the space Doritos the
triangle ships you know to come with
some large people have to come with a
forsaken minimum size piece of content
if not be three oh I don't think they
can do the the like triangle ships in
September or October or whatever it
might be I don't think they can do that
that soon because I don't think it gives
I don't think it gives a new race this
like giant thing we've been waiting for
for years enough wait if they're just
like you know dusty two year three
triangle ships like whatever they're
gonna call it like I don't think that
can happen but they're like they're
playing a really long game
so like take season of the Drifters
invitations design to build something up
for later so it's yeah thing how they're
yeah they're really planting some major
seeds we don't know what's up with
Aldrin yeah that's what I believe God's
everybody knowing that that moment when
he walks back into the tower I just want
to see our chorus face that's what I'm
waiting for
she's gonna be like wait yeah yeah I
feel like the ball is gonna have to like
bubble and we're gonna be like hold on
he doesn't know what he did give me a
second guys
breathe you're good you gotta give us
that I told you so speech see the weak
repercussions of your action so like all
those things are kind of getting set up
so it's I'll be very curious to see what
happens with all of that yeah absolutely
absolutely yeah I think it's the long
play I think invitation on is the long
play my gut tells me d3 that is where
that goes down and then we're still
gonna ever since um we got rid of old
boy domina's goal we've been seeing the
foreshadowing planet to planet of where
we're going content wise and I still
think we're not all the way the riedel's
ready for the phone yeah yeah so we got
Sabbath on we got a bunch you got the
dread-nots coming in you lay back
basically so that's that's the next
piece in the the expansion of the light
that gets hit is the rings of Saturn and
all the ships that were there and all
that stuff that went down that's the
next piece that is honestly probably
would fit the best late yeah for fun
sometimes
my prediction with that Eris we can see
I respect ha I always liked her yeah oh
my guards but like cool and like a lady
who does her voice is awesome when she
like yeah it's like since tingles
through your spine dude when she doesn't
right I was like whoa she's good so yeah
sorry random but yeah so the power surge
bounties will get you up to 690 from
Benedick 99 this is all in tune for
everybody talking about the raid race so
these all pieces are coming together
then we've got gambit bounties we didn't
want the seat the rewards for the
drifter to be one of your primary
sources for power following his run as
the central character for season and
drifter as a result power boost receives
from gambit bounties will decrease once
you achieve 700 so like you know gambit
Prime and reckoning of stuff those would
be pretty decent power little jumps now
they're probably gonna drop down to like
the 1 to 2 level they're gonna be
smaller yeah so those won't be quite as
much they will decrease even further
once you reach 720 and the only certain
things kind of creep up and then have
less effect and less effect so they
always want you pushing on more of the
new stuff mm-hmm
prime attunements so these are how you
get your prime engrams one day when I'm
attunements will be on day 1 prime
attunements will be reset to 2 charges
for each character so no matter if
you've like have a played for a week
feel like you have more saved up when
that server reset happens everybody is
on the same playing field yes sir
so you'll receive two prime nu prime
attunements even if you were playing
right up until the reset which is cool
if doesn't matter how much you have or
haven't basically they just said they
want to be able to play with your
favorite character without you know
impacting your power leveling strategy
so it's not gonna matter which one
better or not so you'll be able to pick
where you want em crown of sorrow raid I
know I'm talking a lot so wait this one
down get into this one this is the big
stuff yeah just a big lemon so yeah the
Chronos our raid begins on day 1
seasonal operants at 4 p.m. Pacific
Standard Time players who want to
complete will need to complete the to
compete will need to complete the power
surge
rest we've taken additional steps to
level the playing field for world first
status and here is the big one more
player power will be capped at power
under each encounter within the rave for
the first 24 hours
so when contest is active players will
face an enforced challenge throughout
the raid this means power beyond certain
levels will provide no advantage for a
given fight example for the first fight
all power above 700 won't provide
advantage and for the final power final
fight power above 720 will not provide
an advantage whoa we got talk about that
oh we are going to deploy the update but
it's the second part of this we're gonna
hit this whole bullet I just wanna
finish the second part of it we're gonna
deploy this update at 8 a.m. Pacific and
the game will be down until 10 a.m.
Pacific so that as many players as
possible can get to the download and
verification step and be ready for
opulence launch shoutout for helping the
PlayStation community because that was
for PlayStation right now but we gotta
go back now they just dropped some some
megatons on us right and shot some
article I got it up right now Lords game
we got net check it out man this is huge
right and this all to me and this is my
absence of an analyzing this thing you
know you know how I've complained about
world's first and it's been a thing
where let's be honest you know a lot of
the higher level guys they have a lot of
hot good crate strats right holding on
to bounties holding on to the primer two
minutes knowing the correct sources way
to go to and I'm in the middle with this
a little bit I think overall that's
where I'm at with this eve I like it but
it's different now because there was a
part of like that strategy of getting
ready for a raid and there were there's
some aspect to it that I did enjoy you
know I'm saying but in in in the realm
of fairness I actually like it because
it's like okay we all want to be on the
same level once you get if I missed or
whatever yield 7:10 and I'm
7:05 we're on the same landfill when we
jump in that first encounter right so
that's gonna be interesting the only
issue I may have I want to see how this
works is I'm all I'm thinking about it's
like Callie when we got Forsaken and we
got to the Callie encounter right we got
to see how hard these encounters are
right that that's the only thing that's
gonna make see how this thing plays out
if these encounters are really tough and
not DPS checks you don't say and if it's
truly strategy this could work if it's
pure if it's DPS checks then I get a
little nervous if everyone's at this
lower power level just for the sake of
fairness right so that that's the only
gray area I want to see but overall my
thoughts are I think this does make it
fair to the masses for people to
coordinate strategize get get in what
they got to get in and more chances for
first day best team winning yeah I'm
saying I think this is closest to the
best that we were to get the best team
as opposed to I held on to all my iron
banner findings and I held on today
tonight you never saying like all that's
out that's a wrap now so I'm done
rambling I'm very curious what do you
think about the 24-hour lockdown what
you gonna do so yeah shout out to expand
on that we had Luke Smith the rare treat
of some words from the man towards the
top of the world of destiny he shouted
out and he just said it's like you know
they've gone through this crazy journey
from vault of glass and different raids
and pushing bosses off ledges and sword
barriers and just like reading that
sense I was like man that's a lot of
nostalgia and one like paragraph but
they're their goal with world's first
races are power progression the
challenges Raiders to climb to compete
the world's first showcase team
communication game strategy and powers
and player skill and a watchable and
fair first race and I think that is the
most important one is fair they're
trying to make this a level playing
field for as many people as possible
because technically you could not power
level at all and you could still be a
on the same level as for that person
counter now when you beat that first
encounter if your 701 and somebody
else's 710 now you're gonna start to
fall behind you gonna feel it so you got
six hours there's still benefits and
they're taking away like raid Keys like
you know if you raid a ton and you have
25 raid keys and you just like do that
multiple times if you can just burn
through it in 6 hours
mmm you could do that but it's like so
they're kind of taken some of that stuff
away there are some bounties to save but
I think most the people who are trying
to have a lot of bounties to turn in
because they'll have your 20 you'll do
you're dreamin city stuff once you're
done with that you can hit those boxes
probably go run shattered throne with
your threes and rotate through that
thing a couple times but generally like
there's only so much you're gonna be
able to do and within an hour capping it
is interesting though cuz I pulled up
the table from a knight mmm and he says
crown of sorrow June 4th recommended
power for first encounter 715 so I'm
honestly wondering if some of the some
things changed in the past like three
weeks yeah yeah like recommended power
7:15 and you're like in six hours that's
already gonna be tough and - you're
capping us yeah we really can't get
there now so if you're saying you want
us to be 7:15 but our power level won't
matter it mattering above 700 those are
that's a change
I think but let me ask you this three
weeks or two with this change do you
think we get more than three encounters
like scorch cuz the vibe I'm getting if
they're doing this to me
I'm just assuming if you do five this
level per each I would see it yeah I
could see that to me this means maybe
more encounters which I'm which I'm a
fan of yeah which I like you know I'm
saying I'm cool with that want more
encounter stuff shot the dramatic he's
also said he's thinking lots of
mechanics and um I'm cool with that - as
long his mind the only thing go caveat
leviathans gonna ray it's a solid rate
my only issue is just not enough
fighting I don't want it all Ninja
Warrior stuff man I don't want to be
running around in the hamster wheel for
this guy I'd only be cleaning no more
basements I don't want it you know I'm
saying like running from dog
at some point let's get some beer man
yes that - let's stick to what work last
wish
some Cali action we got to go up in Cali
you don't face you don't say I'm old you
got one of the most shout - pyro because
he actually said sure oh she is one of
the most underrated encounters always so
cool the the tides I was like sometimes
you may hate time limits but what it
does that that encounters like the
urgency they come together the
communication I got this these guys over
here jump on the plates like yeah that
Sara Chi fight is really really cool
Conner's if they could have I think like
if they bounce maybe just one or two
mechanic II stuff I'm cool but you gotta
let us fight and I'm saying we gotta
fight so I'm just hoping with this Rae
but I think that it may be a chance for
more than more than one with this you
know light level stuff but continue with
the your prediction with the 707 15 all
I can stuff no I mean that's
so you've in the Nate so they phrase it
kind of vague and specific at the tape
same time for the first fight all power
level above 700 won't provide an
advantage and for the final fight power
above 720 will not provide an advantage
so you're like how many are in the
middle is it yeah yeah because you guys
are scores you've got the opening you've
gotten uh the sparrow run and then
you've got the two phases of the final
which is really just the same area say I
think recommend he says I think
recommended power means the ideal level
but recommended power needs to be there
after that's 20 flowers so maybe that's
kind of the ideas like right now this is
like we're gonna like this is gonna be
the challenge for world yeah
after world's first this is and we go
back yeah yeah yeah I think so this way
it gives everyone a fair shot at trying
it if they have mechanics down if they
have their botanics down they do what
they're supposed to do everyone's more
gonna fish yeah I was like I don't know
and that's the whole kind of up and down
I'm with you on it's like I don't want
the power level specifically it's like
when you were 29 in the air it's like
when we were 32 and Colonel Hardin was
33
specifically just artificial difficulty
bite number
those are some of those just things hit
a little harder you don't have white as
much leeway it's like a no raids aren't
meant to be hard but it's like right
it's literally above my level so it's
never a level playing field so it's like
it's like if it's 700 and I'm fighting
something 715 then if in 720 am i
fighting stuff that's like 735 yeah like
that's that point that's the that's the
part of it I wonder it's like if people
make it through the first encounter
you're like okay maybe they burn through
in 6 hours they got up to like 710 maybe
7:15 okay then you go through you do
encounter one encounter - you might get
a couple drop 715 716 717 but he'll make
a 20 power leap at a minimum probably to
get to 735 or 740 where these bosses
tend to end up is towards the higher end
mm-hmm I mean that's a good jump but a
lot of people will not be able to write
like make the leap because if you're
like hey I got to like 705 let's go
check this thing out and you get through
a couple encounters but then you get in
the last one you're like 735 like 30
powers levels below 30 Delta in this
game is a lot when you're under it it is
it is oh it's I can set up in a bit up I
think overall is just different and I'm
not used to it but I don't think it's a
bad thing because I think the other good
thing part of our think about this don't
think about those screens for
world-first
think about how many twitch streams will
be up for this you know we're not gonna
see the same two or three teams that had
those good pre power level strategy you
know power leveling strategies so I
think overall then I'm saying again the
key is gonna be is it so difficult that
it's gonna [ __ ] strippers it's what it
may be
maybe that's what a 24-hour rule comes
into into play where they say you know
what that's their protection if it's too
ridiculous then like almost anti
division right division is like y'all
you just got to do it because that's
what it is it's a one day thing after 24
hours you got your grind you got your
pot things are gonna be in force I'm
coming around on the heat I'm coming I
think I think the 24 hours
key 24 hours yes because if it would
stay like this like how the vision is
doing it we don't care you better then
people gonna get mad like yo I can't
beat this this is insane you you're not
giving me the power jump that I need I'm
at seven whatever it is it's not having
any effect but this is like a Iron Man
thing like yo tough it how you know
whoever gets it gets it you know it's
gonna be yeah that's mean I don't know
if they'll do anything quite as crazy as
the vault because that was insanity to
watch for like six hours we were just
like what does it mean so I mean the
encounters could be interesting but yeah
when you get to the top and I mean as
backup on the set rates are meant to be
a challenge and they will be and I think
this is the point where whatever testing
may have done they have chosen specific
power level specific ability
difficulties where if you are on your
game hating your shots staying alive and
playing smart you will be able to
succeed it's just gonna be real hard at
the top because that last fight if you
can be 720 to fight something 7:35 740
you're gonna be damn near one of the top
yeah if you actually 720 in that final
fight room you are gonna be one of the
top people I think because six hours is
not that long to then start bashing your
head against mechanics yes because like
you have six hours between three
characters and if you can be like okay
so I got some drops in here okay move
some weapons over same thing and then
orangy factoring in seven twelve seven
ten is kind of my guess where people are
gonna be somehow some people are
probably gonna end up at like 719 and be
like how the hell'd you do that I don't
know but yeah but the average raid group
is probably gonna be somewhere in that
715 realm I have a feeling facing that
final encounter that's gonna be tough
they think it's possible they've tested
it out so I know they're gonna be able
to do it but yeah that's that difficulty
that force challenge for that first day
will make the people who get it like
it's gonna be interesting there's me a
very fun one to watch there's the fun
one or washout the Forte he's making a
good point he said I think the new array
will be set up like what's that so to
the past okay four total
encounters plus they may leave room to
bring back challenge mode again normal
mode caps out at 740 prestige is 75
possibility that is a possibility
I actually I don't
on four encounters but uh visit me eat
what does like have you done scourge at
all mm-hmm is it me or is it just like
it's like it feel raid layer it no you
don't feel this on okay the old main
reason I don't feel like it's a raid
layer mmm-hmm cuz that it's completely
on different space it may be a show it's
a so you you're defining raid layer by
length not by location right so that's
what you're thinking to me raid raid
layer that you used to always say is
like apartment to be like right basement
apartment or tower apart like you know
penthouse apartment but it's still going
back to the same location even though
we're in different pieces of content
it was involuntarily fallen raid like so
that was like even blacksmith you had
all those pieces like it was tied to it
to a point but it just feel like it's
still like I don't know something about
that raid that is it just feels I guess
you know what it is to there's no
narrative connection coming off of
forsaken I mean that last wish yes
annually separate yeah that definitely
disconnected me but I just I just need
see the reason why I'm excited for
operas Islamic Sun even though it's
Leviathan again yeah no doubt
but its callous its it's what's the
source of this power there's a story
there's an entry do you want to know
what this is this quest mission have
story depending on what a power search
party is but one would assume based on
Leviathan right when you ended no he the
whole speech and all this other stuff
you know I'm saying it's just like I
need that emotional connection to why
I'm doing said activity yeah I thought
we solved this with last wish right last
which starts up Petra starts talking to
you you feel away you get inside Riven
starts talking to you tricking you doing
the let's go bungee let's
do it you know I'm saying so they're
talking a lot about opulence let's be
real like they've been you know for
opulence we're doing this for opulence
we're doing that we're nerfing that
we're doing this like I need some
information I need to know what's the
hole what's the crown of sorrow I need
get me invested have him start and let's
be honest he started talking he would he
talked all through Leviathan for the
most part I can't say so much about I of
the whatever and you know Shh whatever
of the Stars thirst but I just saw
whatever it had rain layers you know how
I feel about them but at least Leviathan
was a store hopefully if they can
conclude it narrative Lee strong I'll be
okay but like Forte like scotch felt
yeah crota she felt like three rooms
with a spiral way throwing damn it oh
yeah yeah I got written about hotness
read okay I heard some people talking
about Carlos so let me say this about
Chronos little good sewer the open of
crota is really cool that's nice it's
cool automatically not as close later I
go for a go for now that's what it's
like when you think of a red you have to
think of all encompassing of what is it
supposed to feel like it's a hive raid
their crazy creature animalistic and you
have these things running at you the
entire time because little things all
that time this rush and then you have
the high of the sword logic you have the
sword that you use to cross and you hold
down your side back and that was like
some cool mechanics and then you have
like the hero moments in there as well
that I probably have a special spot
because one of my other buddies
that was my two-man flawless raid that's
how I got my platinum in destiny one it
was two man flawless that rain and we
did it in the course of actually a day
which is crazy but like crota has a
special spot because like you have a
raid like vault of glass that is like
time and vex and Nola porting and stuff
like and it and it and it fits the vex
very very well you have the Hydra you
have like the Oracles pinging all over
the place and this is like a more puzzle
that you have to figure out the hive is
just like what are the hive like they're
always like running at you and like the
captain's even though the big weenies
like they had such different fields and
shout out to bund you too
capture such different like tones and
feels within to activities they're not
meant to be raids but they feel so so
different and I thought that was really
really cool so like Kuroda may get some
crap because like you know pulling the
plug or whatever but I was like when you
run it right and you do it like when you
and what's two like two rooms no it's
not it's so small bro you just saw it
across the thing let me tell you why I
like this stupid ring we gonna get that
crota now I'm tired or less crow - crow
- crow - yeah just like it cuz yok is so
low it that's all it is you single guys
which you heroic moment so you can say
look at me I'm a bunch of things that's
all yeah reason why I like that damn ray
it is short it's like two rooms come on
bro that raid is over raid the only the
hottest part about that raid is that the
theatrics of getting the sword the music
hits all right everybody go in a corner
Gjallarhorn it out and then it's over
like hey and the weapons I will say
salute to the weapons curl weapon some
of the best rewards throw - weapons are
hot I'll give you that but let's not act
like this raid was so it's just the guys
that could solo it was like oh this is
cool and hunters that use swords across
a bridge we're taking people through
there'd be like okay follow okay we're
going to two lanterns in a way to
explored okay everybody's good good okay
run like if you were really running with
a team and you did it well
it felt really good brought me tell you
about experience with crota how easy it
is free duo told me do you have
Gjallarhorn yes stay in the corner and
shoot go why like well I do belly I got
drops all I needed was a rocket with
tracking and I got drops all through
this way I literally contributed nothing
it was the ultimate throw somebody in
the backpack
you know it and you know it I'm saying
that you I'm just saying the like it
wind played right uh it was a lot of fun
I think it's just it's one of those like
it was the start we wouldn't have Kings
Falls feel without Kuroda I don't know
about that
like story Ryan that's my voice yeah the
story yeah you don't have crowded dying
and being smashed or expand you killed
my son
I'm pissed like and that feel and then
you get into you know they taking
everything so I was like it was just
yeah the the bridge was like the bridge
trying to figure that thing out for the
first time was nuts like okay so run
across build the bridge how long do we
sit here how do we survive
holy crap now there's three people on
their side we're split and there's a lot
of stuff spawning over here like the
wind that encounter is done well and the
way it's built for not choosing it and
and Gjallarhorn breaking encounters I'm
just saying like when you take the raid
for what it's intended to be not the way
you're gonna cheese the crap out of it
because you can choose Riven now to
that's very very different calyx five
amazing encounters but prior oh I'm not
saying you're doing and I'm gonna saying
last wish isn't one of the best trades
ever I'm just saying Kurt against a lot
of crap and I don't think it should get
as much of a dumpster like as it gets so
we I just pray it's it's it's just
interesting to me to see how much people
love it the way they do I mean I would
still say the majority probably agrees
with me as far as ranking of we're
quarters but it's interesting to people
who love it like yourself like the
Pyro's stuff like that you know it's
interesting here yeah like Revere about
this ray and I'm like literally I sat in
the corner and shot gala horns and over
like like there was nothing this one guy
Billy
alright guys shoot him go I did it to
really don't like sounds some of the
stratifying single-player raid I was
like this the solo stuff was cool cuz
you could do that but it was also the
point to where it felt really cool to be
the sword bear not the galley guy on the
back when you were the sword bear you
were like the whole raid team is on my
shoulders I have to clutch up now that
was like and you know there's they've
gotten away from yeah me well I don't
know what you mean but you are right
I'll give you this you're right and only
this portion of mechanics with a solo
guy being able to save the encounter
that I give you they've gone away from
that they don't allow people to like
before like it was like now in destiny
rates like if one person right white you
screw alright everybody let's do it you
don't say most you know one person like
they allowed you to continue because of
that mechanic so in that sense I gotta
what hold on he says sorry or Forte
sorry I look like voter glasses third
breast race Cinque hold he got kicked
for one breath wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait you're about to get
booty loan we gonna put you on time I
had the audacity to say that vaulted
glass is the third best Rick you don't
even have last wish above it if you
wanna said last wish I might let you
slap King's fault is debatable rather
the machine is one of my favorite rays
it's fun but let's not act like that's
better than thought of class-d the
immortal be legendary falter and let me
let me let me shut down your after the
Machine real quick because much as I
love that rate we fought the Cable Guy I
call him the cable dad I got it comes
out in the front we throw the dog when
he fought him twice in the rain for that
same guy twice so that exact that's
automatic deduction of points before the
same dude so that that's out of it
Kings for I'll give you if you like I'm
a hardcore rate like a man's raid I'll
give you that that's just tomato tomahto
sour woman you know
whatever so at the end of the day but
don't shoot
yeah disrespect Guardians have changed
their fate
are you crazy that a Gorgon are you
kidding me some of the best weapons ever
in brain history outside of Corona
are you kidding me we're go ahead as
multi-class and we ain't gonna do it
we're gonna do it game before t I was
liking you using you you messed up the
deck
like what like this is where I'll say
you're wanting oh we got stopped pocket
rose-colored are you kidding me we gonna
have to do a poll
let me ask you this question before you
even doing this
about to go in but good that was vault
your first raid absolutely okay that's
not rose-colored glasses mom no no that
is gonna be an experience no matter what
game you experienced your first raid in
like me molten core in World of Warcraft
mm has a special place like your and I'm
not and I'm not taking down vault of
glass I'm not saying there's a different
we not gonna do this well not no I'm not
there's a den I spent week I let me
finish my point and I'll get you back is
yeah we're gonna do this here's the
thing there's a difference between
seeing something for the first time and
being enamored it still has to be good
that's the king and I never said it
wasn't right I was what I'm trying to
say is yes there's always gonna be a
nostalgia because it was the first but
it had to be good if it's not good it's
not gonna be memorable I can name three
to four encounters in that raid which
were amazing that still haven't really
been done that at the time splitting
that Duff actually Leviathan bit hiding
from something you know I'm saying like
when ad the dog that's literally Gorgon
on the next level you had the jumps come
on like it even the initial start you I
talked about coolness with how crotas
start right oh this is cool we jump down
what you call it's cool yet to build the
spire people hold down a spot many
people hold down a spot
it was very I'm gonna say the word it
was it was iconic for its time nothing
at that time in gaming in console gaming
was doing that so that's what I gotta
say that's why I'm not gonna allow the
slander so continue knock I'm done
interrupt you say anybody's first
encounter is gonna have a special spot
like me I picture the first time going
through vault of glass working together
is cool but I'm also sitting there in my
mind comparing and I'll always compare
this game to world because that was a
40-person rate and you want to talk
about communication roles
Keeler's tanks like DPS like watching so
much going on like let's do a whole
different level of things that like we
still never touched but I was like for a
first raid on console like they built
something
shout out to division having some they
built it tough but balanced tough but
fair type on normal like because you
knew that it like what 26 type mmm yeah
yeah something you think of the
encounters so you're like how many so
how many bosses did you have involved
you had to you got up guy you had our
home what's-his-face Spinney guy
pellicle III
don't be technical you got green care
disrespect to go we can't disrespect
what can't distress to Gore going he was
if you saw you that's a wiping count
that's a white mechanic that's not a bus
you can kill it
that's not a boss it doesn't have a
specific name but it was an encounter
I'm saying encounter not boss difference
okay that's all I'm saying so we'll
subtract points because it wasn't a
mathematical boss I'm saying number of
buses in Vault okay versus number of
bosses in other raids isn't a big
argument because there are encounters
right they're not boss fights it's a
difference so that's what I'm saying
like that piece now the rewards in vault
were one of the best because yet fate
bringer you had what was that damn scout
rifle um oh my god vision of confluence
is really conv weight very because we
talk about the legendary vex mythoclast
see I never really enjoy that thing took
me way too long and it was gone oh my
god he needs a prime Bungie had to
support a stop to that it was just so
dominant broom then we had the arm was
your epilogue yeah it wasn't that a
machine gun that was really beasty too
when you fighting or a fight
oh my god so many legendary weapons you
know I'm saying it's just iconic III
can't and then in like I said the last
boss vice people are really underrating
the whole 80 on joint I was an amazing
mechanic that this
of the two teams into three each would a
specific role and you gotta fight your
way back through time to come back to
your night as a six to get that cup row
that was I kind of knew Katie that was
amazing amazing we not going
disrespectful
it's not about Jess oh it was nostalgic
it was the first and I have rose-colored
glasses my glasses got rose because it
was different no it was great
like literally like the game let's be
real also with the history of destiny if
that thing didn't exist
in the fashion it was most people
wouldn't even stick around for destiny
alright
mostly woody we stick around right now
because I've been hearing this like
people trying to slander the only two
raids that you can put next to my fault
right and I will not argue with you and
I will say you know what
tomato tomahto is taken King if you say
taken King as your best rape kognito
leaves you look you know what you like a
true challenge boss fights get at to you
and I'm saying if you say last wish I'm
like you know what as a complete raid
can't knock it it's up there up esse the
reason why wrath is described which and
my draft is my most fun raid at the most
fun playing wrath but the reason why
wrath is automatically disqualified one
because like I said they really count
herself a short the it's the fact that
you fought the same guy back six or
whatever his face now I will give you
the end love the end part that was
amazing I love the mechag someone's back
doing stuff cool music great rewards I
will give that and what was that thing
in the middle yeah the C's machine in
the middle that's it but other than that
it is what it is he could say whatever
he like but we could do the poll you not
going to slander this vote to glass the
goat it is the goal all right that's it
Oh discussions over
now 40 you're not invited on the show a
woke the Beast to you about crying
sounds like he was like what I mean it's
like not all raids are gonna be created
equal same intention or otherwise and
you have people of different mentality
saying hey some things get too long and
they like an experience of like scourge
if you have a decent group can be done
very quickly but you still get to
experience something like you get to
experience a really cool set of
encounters you have the Sparrow run you
get to like coordinate with your team
and things like that there are cool
pieces to every raid and I'm just
honestly curious to see what this one
has I'd love to see the for like a four
piece for for encounters three bosses
would be nice
I want night I'm with you I do want boss
fights cuz you think of late hey let's
open the door okay let's go through this
maze okay let's open the vault
let's you know played you know Ninja
Warrior whatever it is you're gonna do
like those are those are cool encounters
of survival and mechanics but the
survival and mechanics that's life like
kings Falls a hard one for me to beat
because you had so many bosses you had
the war priests you had golgoroth which
is still one of the best fights ever
like I do bro I will fight you I was
like you had the daughters you had Oryx
you had you had the maze-like
there and you had the tower you had like
six encounters on that one fact and I
reason why I won't even fight you if
anybody I came at me with that is
because let's be real we first saw Oryx
from you that's like one of the best
moments the yes see like I was just like
y'all like didn't just did the mechanics
knee that was us out amazing right yeah
that was an amazing great III do now
only knocked off I'm gonna pick just a
new for my voice I got I got a hold down
for vol there's no weapons a chat but I
feels like oh well maybe
tucked autorad sucked pulse rifles good
sniper was good gun was good
those three Chico was the best was it
term quick Willems Quilmes terminus now
that was everybody's gone for like two
years
sniper was salad also a lot of people
really like that now it introduced to
one of the best mechanics we ever had
the auto reload put it away and just
come back oh yeah but then they gave it
to every dude came later
but yeah that was that was something I
was just like I didn't know how much I
would appreciate that until I had it
what was the Scout was something of
chalice yes I'm like that like probably
no Chad scalp it was bad but no they
Auto rifle was awful the worst in the
hand cannon it was somehow worse than
that mobiles were so tall it was like a
reskin of every gun but I was the very
that was a very very somatically focused
like yeah look like they all came out of
but I mean it's like the taken king
dreadnought they all do you know where
those weapons came from it's not like
hey I found this one I need easy no that
didn't came from the dreadnought so I
mean they were thematically focused but
yeah there were some couple really trash
ones in there okay now I'm just dip
picker because that raids amazing yeah
that's honestly that one on the last
wish are probably the two longest traits
of everything they're even longer longer
than vault by encounters cuz King Saul
had the open the door then you have the
warp raises then you had golgoroth then
you had the maze then you had the
daughters then you had or otters
so that's the difference where some
people will get into jumping puzzles -
jumping puzzles - cuz you had a
spaceship I forgot about a wall yeah I'm
saying it now going snow I say anything
sexual in the [ __ ] cast I give you
trouble yob just like mark our audio
podcast I don't have to click ensure
mm-hmm but that's true like took the
elemental power away from primary
weapons that's I mean everything's has
their ups and downs - but it's like for
length of encounters like and something
or like hey do you want to go run
Kings fall where do you want to run last
wish and some people like God that could
take a long so there are so with egg
that's your agreement right there saying
sometimes the shorter not the layers but
like a scourge a we're a thumbs up yeah
that's where I simply wrap over back
like that's when it's like depending on
what you want in that moment is some
people want it to be a little shorter a
shorter but more full encounter laying
full mechanics and bosses and stuff like
that but not let's go run King Saul all
right babe I'll talk to my wife in like
five hours and skip dinner like that was
a time investment yeah so I mean that's
why they've had these shifts of like
huge content forsaken drop big giant
raid smaller content okay here's another
raid you can do it's smaller for us to
build but it's small also for people to
like be able to run it more pull more
people through not know it's not a crazy
long investment of time so that's why I
was like I don't hold the length always
against it me neither so that's I just
want rat the Machine level fun and
length like if they can give us wrath a
machine level scourge again it just
gotta get connection to the content we
have to get connection to Calais you
know I'm saying that that's that's all I
don't we going off on a super tangent
this is like a great point yeah but is
it just one of those things I want to
talk about because they this got the
potential to really be something nice
you know I'm saying wid Calais we all
want to know what is the crown of sorrow
what is this power he wants to help us
and I just want some some storyline
aspect to it they do that I'm brilliant
so yeah giant raid tangent out of the
way oh yeah I'm like it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting to see how the
power caps go raid race might have more
people involved because the people who
people have less required time off it's
like if you're gonna be like hey I'm
gonna take off two days I'm not gonna
take off three and then the weekend or
all these things just like now Granite's
in the middle of the week some point I
wish they would release a raid
like Saturday at like 10 o'clock just
like have the weekend to work on it you
can do your play during the week or
something like that be kind of cool but
they never seem to do things then but
honestly I'm really curious to see how
it goes
it should I don't I mean they're still
skilled Raiders like sweat circle and
glad that team of redeem is like they
have a mindset to work on those things
and pick apart puzzles and figure it out
and that's skill on a whole different
level that levels not gonna matter and
now we're really gonna find out is this
a power leveling talents is it the
skills or is it both so no I agree and
that's why I can't wait to see who
actually gets this jacket who ever get
no disrespect to price winners I dis
jacket to me is gonna mean a ton more
you know I mean I want to see who pulls
it off so yeah we also have another
change coming next season yeah we've got
ever verse getting a little bit of a
tweak little I mean like overhaul of the
store so with season of opulence were
having some changes to Evers now as
before we get into ever us and listen to
DCP last night shadow to them and what
we've said to if ever verse gets at
overhaul but the vendors are still the
same sadface that's one of those things
that has been missed for so long of like
going in on weekly reset and seeing like
hey what are the roles on what was that
hand cannon that the crucible robot sold
every so often that was like
occasionally a god role Oh was it a
palindrome yes like that so like I was
like stuff like that when you log in
it's like all you check is the director
and ever verse like my weekly reset gets
shorter and shorter it's like you can do
your night falls in this stuff it's like
and they haven't hit those vendor resets
in so long and I honestly am not holding
my breath that's gonna happen this
season I'm not but whatever comes next
that has to really be a thing if it's
not d3 and that's more RPG mechanics
employee no but like like fall that
falls to start happening again be like
have different gear have different roles
like have a set that rotates every like
some of those things be an option like
you can have just random like algorithms
to be like I don't know throw armor up
there and throw a set of perks on it you
got to be level 10 to pick it all up and
there's a different gun every week and
different perks you have random like
each vendor could have that and you have
more benefit we've talked about set
bonuses and now I wish there was like
hey I go to Titan and there's like a
hive set and I go to etz and there's a
fallen set like there's many many things
they could do and this is where I think
the set bonus of season of The Drifter
was like testing the waters mmm-hmm and
stuff I hope to see more but like if
ever vs. gets this type overall and the
vendors it's just like man it's I know
every verse is there and like some
things seem to be positive out of this
update but don't forget about the rest
here guys like there's a lot of interest
out there they're just like I've been
staring at this inventory for two years
yeah like bro can we get some loves and
get some usage for some of these vend is
it until what's up with faction rally
fam
yeah that's come on that's section I
mean I'm not even gonna bring up the
other one the sore subject but faction 2
is like yeah I don't know fall I'm gonna
have I'm out of questions for I need to
see some cuz novelist is the last part
and then I'm gonna be quiet yeah I feel
until we know yeah as we don't so we
have two main goals for the changes were
making ever versus per season opulence
direct pick every new ever verse item in
season of opulence will be a very now
this is where I have a question of how
this works
every new ever verse item in season of
opulence as long as they follow that
language will be available for direct
purchase via silver or bright dust
that's a huge if that holds because the
picture doesn't look like that but if
that works that way that is really
really cool because spending time and
playtime you are not required to buy
silver right there's no like hey here's
a bundle that's silver only like that
was kind of like well I mean what is it
this week the old fighter ship old
fighter sparrow guy
most of these offers will be limited
time which I'm okay with what the bright
dust with new items available weekly
kind of gives it a fresh rotation
greatest in season of opulence bright
engrams will contain a collection of
community favorite legacy items with a
focus on the best of year
one if you missed out on spicy ramen or
selfie season of opulence is your chance
so bring them back some old favorites
bringing some new stuff in mm-hmm
here's see here's where I wonder if
there's a distinction
every new ever versus item in season of
opulence if the old ones are still gonna
be like silver only bundles I'll be
curious if that's how they make that
distinction so some additional details
armored full armor sets will be made
available as a single per class bundle
as opposed to being offered via Brad and
Gramps what do you think about that
right there first before I go any
farther full bundle of armor so you just
buy the armor set you want to look like
that
but yeah I like that I like that because
like I used to miss stuff like that I
would love that for the all when the
dawning was because I love that set you
know I mean just having a play oranjee
and all I'm game just to get every
single part so yeah if you like a set go
get it like that bundle thing don't love
it and then hold on one second sorry so
that's actually cool just by the bundle
no like orangey question mark situate
like and the nice thing is you'll know
all the perks because individual armor
pieces can be purchased for bright dust
whenever they appear on storefront so
you'll be able to get certain pieces
these armor pieces feature fixed perk
pearls that are not randomized across
duplicates so you can either buy the
full set or you can go for the random
rolls but if you get one you have it so
if you just want to be like straight-up
first day buying that set cool what if
it's got decent perks on it that could
be you know just it was like they're
probably not gonna be Opie but seeing
like enhanced perks on that let's just
say that yeah clearly because you know
they'll get killed you know people be
like Oh video will come out
microtransactions they're giving you
know that you do know you know not it's
just like yeah it's gonna be set might
be trash rolls but yeah this is that
right there is why they desperately need
transmog because if I'm like buy a
straight set and I want to look like
this and I'm just like cool I want to
look like this all the time bought it
done apply
visual effect done
like yes that is when that needs to come
in there yeah especially with the
priming gram system the atonement system
and having it just always look
disgusting just for the sake of light
level like that is frustrating so the
average mom yeah and it perks you're
right you're absolutely right mmm a
simpler interface specific items are now
featured on the front page when we
cycled each week most offers will be
time limited to make their way for
rotating Livernois some come back into
rotation at a later date players can
access this new interface by visiting
tests in her usual tower location so if
you guys go to the table you can see
it's a pretty cool picture you've got
ever verse on the Left the featured
stuff what you can buy for brightness
whether it's a sparrow and ornament
shader you got the weekly offerings
which will be the limited whether it's a
couple emotes they've got a couple
multiplayer ones ornaments you got this
crazy sparrow which looks like it's from
the tron and then just behind some
bright engrams and you've got other
stuff on the left-hand side so it's more
of a menu to sketchily go through which
is kind of cool so yeah if they and
that's my question that says those
weekly offerings and those show all
silver but it also is like everything
can be bought for silver or bright dust
so I don't know if you click on and you
pick how you want to buy it or something
I'll be curious how that's implemented
if there's anything that is pure silver
only because the way you read that same
and it shouldn't be yeah it shouldn't be
the other pieces wrapped items and
refunds which is a rare treat individual
items purchased for silver right will
now go to the relevant character
inventory as I wrapped any wrapped state
example a sparrow purchase directly will
go will arrive in a wrapped in the
Sparrow inventory to use an item must be
opened just like a bundle once open the
item functions and can be used but also
not returned so if you buy it and you're
like you can undo it as long as you
don't open the package like if all tags
are on your product and is in original
condition you can return within 92 I'm
just kidding sounds like a story but
these little pictures down here actually
pretty cool so you've got well it looks
like kind of like a ghost shell with
like two little camping bags on the side
you've got a couple ghost projections
couple ornaments look cool
the Siva hunter ones look pretty cool
shell yeah like O'Doul looks really cool
yep and other like so I reversal just
I'll be curious how it looks I know they
say all the new stuff should be
purchasable with brightness or silver I
still feel like there's going to be some
stuff that is just silver only because I
just have a hunch but we will see but
there's one more piece of this 12 that
is probably the most important of
everything go for it it's the final
section so and deeds wrote this one by
the way it's been a while it's been a
while and in proper deeds fashion the
vague wonders of what will come in the
future he's damn good at it yes good
these are some of the game changers you
oldest changers you will discover when
season of opulence begins but we have
even more to show next week or already
working on a preview of new Pinnacle
weapons which will be showed we've seen
a preview of the new raid jacket that is
totally awesome with a with the finer
points for the systemic changes on table
we can next turn our attention to
revealing the places we'll go and the
reasons you'll fight that's opulence
right now our focus is opulence but the
season has launched and rate belts have
been awarded will be looking deeper into
the future and sharing with you more
about a new era for Bungie and destiny
to specifically button up and stay tuned
our so obviously season of opulence is
the focus next week we get pinnacle
weapons and buffs and patch preview and
stuff like that so there's one part of
that line and they here they D just very
specific about his word choice he always
is oh you're a mastiff sharing you with
more about our new era for Bungie and
destiny - mmm not three not three not
any like in the future of destiny as a
franchise as a whole and just the
franchise that destiny - so if three is
in the works with everybody thinks it is
they're not talking about that bro we we
talking about fall it sounds like yeah I
mean the vibe I'm getting is like they
stand on track of what they normally do
um what the difference is um obviously
they've never had
us like this the first time they're
having summer content so to speak with
this annual pass having appellants come
out and around the time it's coming out
so the vibe I'm getting is there gonna
be utilizing this to speak about the
next thing in the fall and the critic
question just becomes when is that next
thing there's a like we've always had
that discussion based on what else
exists in September so yeah we got a see
we got to see but it looks like they I
mean a vibe I'm getting look like they
kind of you know they still on track
what they go and do so yeah lishus so I
mean you sit there and you look at dates
of when things like their pins that stop
going on sale August 31st okay
weekly resets its through September
first or second mm-hmm
so Tuesday would be September 3rd right
which is neither let's take just the
data of said vorlons gray September 13th
okay ten days mmm-hmm you got Monster
Hunter which they probably really don't
see is true competent even though it's
one it's just it's on ready but more
dalliances probably their biggest threat
that's too big so do you as Bungie and
that's kind of one of those things where
some people will take the two games in
different ways yeah Borderlands has now
it has New Game+ you can go through it
again and again but you're looking at
something to where you technically and
not a lot of people they'll be like hey
I played Borderlands maybe I went throw
it on a different character but at some
point Berta let Borderlands for more
often than you're crazy dedicated only a
start to finish path right so that's a
bright to where say hey Bungie comes out
there's this new thing now I don't think
it'd be smart to launch a raid on the
13th like 10 days after they did last
wish that wouldn't be smart because it'd
be like well you guys suck but also
launching quick would be kind of an
issue because then you make people burn
through new content so right man I don't
know this is when we don't know
the next Reese that's the next weekly
reset more like the hell comes next
right yeah go go go like I'm just
sitting here thinking in my head if that
vodka bottles gonna accuse me to talk to
I think I filled up the first half here
okay all right cool my quota now this is
listen if they're gonna do it they look
based on DJ's language and we're
assuming it seems that they're still
they're not backing down so if we're not
going back down we gotta be strategic
so this is what I proposed we know that
the third time you said the 12th right
or the 13th is when Thor 13th is one boy
Lance is coming out 13th is Borderlands
yep so we know appellant's launches with
their raid at the same time if you
really want to get gangster you could
drop one to 70 and say okay 13 comes is
the hype cycle you know 17 we try to
take some people away we get the fever
of a raid if they if they continue on
point with this if opulent strategy is a
success right if chrono sorrows is a
success and they'd this day one rating
becomes a thing then they could have a
trump card whenever the launch of the
next content is because if they let's
just for example let's just say they
have a forsaken level style
well not not exactly but close to write
a bigger first chunk of Annual Pass if
we're assuming they continue with Annual
Pass structure right but the rumors are
that this first piece of annual pass
will be substantial more than usual
right almost to mimic a comment if they
do that and if they do first day rate
right you got a you got a a serious
weapon because the community is going to
galvanize that release date so if I said
yo new Joyce out we got to get ready
community is gonna get especially if
it's good and it's some good concert
let's say they go to Sabbath tune they
start giving us
feels of things that we wanted I'm not
gonna get excited and say trial but
let's just say there's other active
activities that's your trump card let's
just say all the stuff we've been
complaining
cuz that's all I got a duty let's be
honest right srl trials faction rallies
solid raid solid store new strikes
vendor update vendor updates but that's
it this is where we get some that debate
it's like how much can they squeeze into
September like they give me game two
strikes bro ain't give me - sure bro
your to stretch right now story
give me something right refreshes if
it's not hit at some new activity that
sounds cool you draw all that with the
hype of a day one last wish coño good
bring it I don't think you can do day
one rage I think I think if it's a
success don't eat you can do that for
something that as big as you want though
this is the past like extension of the
year this isn't like a new store you
can't ask people to burn through story
and six hours and just completely it
that's what we really want know but
there's no story there's one little baby
quest that's probably like an invocation
of the nine possibly we go see but
that's why like I don't know like if you
mmm but it's like I mean what would your
level be like I don't think they're
gonna be like hey this is a fifty power
level bump for you know a September
piece it's interesting I think they can
do a day one right in September I really
don't like I'm not saying if it works
like it's not a good idea
mmm but I think it works in this
situation I mean okay of an annual pass
because if you have a bigger piece of
like hey couple strikes you've got new
crucible maps you've got some story
missions like if all the other stuff is
still there I don't even know if people
would do any of that stuff unless
required by like hey you have to make
through the story to open the raid
but I was like you you ruin the content
we've always said like it sucks when
they make us burn through stuff that's
why the 10 days her last wish was it was
long and the grind was long and people
got you know extra high by abusing stuff
and if they just like see I think they
could power cap it I think that'd be the
thing I think they could give you more
time not day 1 but if they power cap the
raid and be like hey day 1 raid race
we're all starting at 8:15 I don't know
what pick a random is number but mmm
pick a number where you're like your
power capped if you're above that cool
but everybody's fighting the stuff over
so they send the difficulty that would
be a way I think they could pick the
time to release and be like right where
do we want to like strategically
position to be like hey you play
Borderlands over that we can come back
to the raid on Tuesday like the 17 were
said to be like now I'm gonna put back a
little bit with our raid so I think that
would be I don't think they can do a day
1 race for a brand new piece of content
that's my opinion the old in normally I
completely agree I don't say I still
think they can do what you're saying
that's that would be par for the course
that would be what they normally do I'm
very curious to see engagement with
opulence because I'm very curious to see
if the community is galvanized by the
content if they're galvanized by this
world's first restructure they're making
it a point II I mean we're getting a
whole table on this raid power leveling
so when I see that type of stuff from
Bungie historically this is the new
direction they're going so I am and
let's be real like what we hear is fall
is another season pass set up and you'll
pass that up so yeah that it doesn't
make things accelerated and fast
you know the blaze to content yeah not
gonna I'm not gonna say it's not is it
ideal probably not but if I'm just I'm
just concerned if they have success with
what they're doing right now and this
seems to be the direction they're going
that they may bring this bad boy right
on back and say hey maybe we give you
two days maybe we launch Tuesday ago
today you know and do one of them type
deals maybe they do that and extend it
today
level-3 what yeah Matt that dad is this
for I don't see put it this way my gut
tells me I don't see it going like a
week from release like the old way yeah
I don't see the stems sitting that long
so yes I mean speed might be of the
essence to have people burn what they
can and then they know people are gonna
chuck are gonna go play borderlands not
everybody but I mean a chunk are gonna
go play especially like the streamers
are gonna be leavin for a little bit
check out the new new digs mm-hmm but
yeah it's like what they do to what they
do to space it's tough out to try and
pull people back or things like that'll
be interesting too so no and then also I
mean you think about season of opulence
and I feel like you mentioned this maybe
offer at another point the timing of
opulence with June 4th around III do you
think that is a factor for the day one
push do you think this is like hey let's
experiment with this because of this
then they talk about the timing of after
the rain jackets are awarded they
probably won't be shipped that it was
that takes a while but when they're
awarded I mean III is the next week do
you think they have a presence do you
think they wait after around before
where my spider sense is tingling I
think they're up to something
I think they're up today's to me they're
it's too coincidental that they are
doing this during the week right now we
do know some things we know activating
does not have a conference yeah we know
Sony will not be at the cop however I
find it interesting that Bungie is
deciding to do this during that we got
biggest it was like what's the best way
to get attention to your game announced
something during e3 week I wouldn't be
surprised I wouldn't be surprised
something big happens during that and
they they really start narrowing down
some type of future of death to the hint
leaked what's going on
something kind of bombastic and to get
juices riled up again for the fall so
was it it's gonna be during e3 week like
not the fourth through seventh but like
that eighth through 15th whatever like
yeah
difference to start that weekend and
then the public's knowing that week do
you think it'll be sometime during that
week I think they'll conveniently make
some form of a statement if not trailer
of something to say hey V I'll look out
for this to get the height height rollin
I mean we're I mean would they stream
their own it wasn't it on a stage cuz
the only real stage non-pc would be
Microsoft you steel it's there that's
because you're not gonna do it with like
moving there's no like I mean Hoover's
office Corinne English I'm gonna give
you I'm gonna give you up free I was
saving this for one more week but this
is my May II so I got a SAS bill to
beans
this is the big Cognito connect the dots
puzzle there could be nothing it could
be completely wrong this is what I'm
going bro I am convinced that
something's cooking because here's a
dead we know deal ends right the Sony
exclusivity deal and we hope no no it's
a fax out the home law we got that we
got it's a fact that that agreement in
conclude in conjunction with Activision
that's over in the fall so opulence is
the last old content on the old or old
agreement they're done so what I'm
saying is they got to start planning all
ready for the next suitor so to speak if
they plan to go that route which is
where I'm guessing and I'm guessing that
even though that what is it Nettie's
Monday's okay but that's mobile stuff I
think that they're gonna be in a
situation where they're not gonna want
to be brought out like exclusively but I
think Microsoft steps in with the
marketing rights I think just a
marketing deal just to say hey you come
on on our stage and you we I don't think
cuz one thing about Phil Spencer and
this shout out to Phil Xbox nation all
you guys here's the thing one thing
about Phil II hard core destiny player
oh no hardcore hardcore that's his
favorite game right Bungie we already
know the relationship but I don't think
they want to get tied in
I think about their independence I don't
paint exactly so what could and Phil
doesn't want his one thing about Phil
Spencer
he doesn't like exclusive deals but even
when he got division right on xbox they
got the marketing rights it was an
exclusive deal that they got with oh you
only got this exotic on division here
you know I'm saying so I think that's
what happens and then here's the other
thing we just got the announcement
whereas your servers right and Sony
right
I think they kick it off on Microsoft
stage exclusive you've got a hint of the
future a little trailer comes out and we
say cross play cross progression in the
future because we know Bungie wanted to
do it already we got the documentation
right are you with me on this are you
with my conspiracy theory right now yes
I don't think they're gonna tie
themselves to anyone anymore
specifically which is a marketing deal
though no but I don't think I don't I
don't want to deal if you get the
commercial that's it well I understand
that piece of it but also think Bungie
is not gonna spend what like the time in
III and they they prefer their live
streams they prefer their them
controlling the messaged each sitting on
the couch taking you through whatever
it's gonna be
they prefer their reveals their Vioxx
anything of that nature in-house produce
content and I don't see that being on
any stage honestly I don't see them
they're gonna I think don't let III die
and my assumption is gonna be a week or
two after III once that dust has settled
because that is a lot of crap going on
and they don't want to get lost they
would other be like hey here's all the
previews and stuff like this that'll
give it a little breath like breath of
fresh air and then be like hey we got a
stream coming on Wednesday the you know
20th of June or something like that
that's my hunch is that they will still
be very separate from III the only
reason why I disagree is to that point
which is again not illogical which isn't
the reason why I disagree is because
we've got to remember
they had the same deal when it would
Sony and they had the trailer but we saw
the cave death on in a short snippet it
was during that whole III cycle and it
was literally buried between four major
games that's the bus spider-man the same
thing and they and long as because their
thing is the long as they get eyes on it
you know says long it does have to be in
depth it literally couldn't be a
five-minute trailer of a three-dose
cinematic of space torito's and Charlie
whatever would ya whatever the next
content is right you would too early for
space but it could be literally Aldrin
walking into the town and and people
ready to shoot him with a mess whenever
that happens I like he's standing
he brought the breathe breath that's a
fun work no but I was like whenever he
finally comes into the mix man that's
gonna be such a mess and the other
question is they need a PC Souter no
more what you call it but on that too
that's my life is gonna be like spin the
road I'm taking two bags one for
Microsoft for console um marketing
rights no exclusive content they're
gonna dig it get rid of but they'll go
you get the marketing right so you could
talk about on our stage and I can see
epic back in the truck upsell oh I heard
you a single looking for a PC a platform
like yeah it's like destiny to is still
like a thing and it's gonna be a
continuation and expansion of that
platform I'm still seeing Activision
whole like being your piece Battlement
being your PC support somehow I think
that's still gonna be through d2 I don't
think a big honest also is I love
battlenet was like and that's fine with
me
crying we're still dedicated servers but
I think if you're gonna make a switch it
has to be for d3 I think 2020 d3 when
you're doing new consoles you also look
at a new platform because that's when
they're gonna have like the whole earth
blow up and that's where your vaults
gonna go and that's how they're gonna
reset everything that's when you can
make that switch I don't think you can
pull ABI like all that stuff off a
battlenet me
like okay now the expansion will play on
epic I don't think that happens yet next
year maybe I though the deal does die it
is curious what happens then oh oh no
III so yeah you're learning during a
three you know mmm
we'll probably know a lot before
Guardian Cana no I'm buying you it over
yes sir
Oso Series Game of Thrones yeah yeah
that's something that's fine
even though I feel like we're yeah we'll
see so yeah some time before Guardian
con is probably when I expect to see the
trailer but I don't expect to see it
neither I feel like that's too too much
going on I feel like they like their own
stage to me but I also see the mic if
they would it would be straight up at
Microsoft's I don't think they would do
it anywhere else but I don't think they
just getting out of PlayStation want to
dabble in the other piece either so
money talks brother I know
people drop a bag of funny you push
things change so when it goes Sony would
be playing with Microsoft right now
you're as I mean that that's only a
direct compare Phil likes them we'll see
no okay but like you said in fairness to
you it it literally could be what you
said they kiss they can wait they can
say hey it's just too early we don't
have to talk about it right now
we can dominate the new cycle later so
that is a valid point either way but
yeah so we've got the future lights
being we're looking we're getting close
but yeah
June 4th man get ready mm-hmm you got
not long
so start saving any bounty as you can
figure out what you're gonna do in the
Dreaming city if you want any powerful
gear get your team ready if you got six
people I might try and go blind I'm not
gonna race trying to go blind actually
go let's go so that I think would be fun
because honestly Rath I did blind
completely and those fun so I wouldn't
mind seeing it blind and being like hey
guys shut off to which I don't care I
just want to play for fun I'll go check
the mechanics later
jump in with somebody and be like let's
see what happens cuz I know I'll have a
seven hundred character I don't know if
I'll have three I can really burn
through as efficiently but honestly like
going on to some people just to eat you
ly be able to see the first encounter at
seven hundred guaranteed now we know
that so incomplete I think that would be
cool so if you're looking at going and
blind hit me up on Twitter PC for that
day I think that'll be fun for sure I
think I'm taking off work bro that's not
no take it off I'm not even gonna lie
I'm not gonna hold you I'm doing it bro
so if you ya put me in the hole I'll hit
up sinister I'll hit up anak y'all let's
do it man let's get some black get it
poppin so yeah we'll be talking we'll
have even more to talk about next week
on that but before we wrap up guys I
know this is a long one today yeah we
got our comp and raid tangents and
everything division twos raid who has
been beaten yes
I'm more than just one or two people now
but despite what people think they're
not changing it they're leaving it as is
interest what do you think on that
because basically the big debate is PC
versus console the just basically the
ability for your mouse and keyboard over
controller once you can do like your
ability to be more accurate at ranged a
little more detail little speed and
being able to move all those pieces are
a factor mm-hmm and it took console and
I think consoles gotten better since
more people are guests are figuring out
tricks but like right there does seem to
be a pretty decent disparity it feels
like now here in fairness to that lungi
with last wish
I think cactus was the only clan yeah in
the first 24 hours on console so you
know that's a cactus but there are a lot
more on PC as well so again do you get
into a point of like it console is just
one of those things with controller and
you can't just whip around like you can
with a mouse versus do you think the
difficulty needs to be changed adjusted
I mean from what I've heard some of that
stuff is and I watch people beat their
heads against the wall
but I mean it's a raid it's meant to be
hard so what do you think gonna get your
thoughts I'm conflicted with this one
man to be honest and normally I'm of the
hardcore look it's meant to be hard
you gotta get busy it's just it's so
unforgiving as far as did the level of
completions at this point mm-hmm that I
am concerned cuz let's not act like you
know console guys are not trying really
hard I mean we all know yes PC has the
advantage with friends is no doubt right
that is a straight advantage the only
thing I'm concerned in yeah shout the
[ __ ] amount of loadings fast as well the
only thing as I'm concerned is that if
this many people are not completing it
you got like one completion on you know
whatever and I don't know him like 36
hours to do which is also just like what
they fall asleep and like Twitter since
every soft and so they didn't thing down
I'm a little concerned I'm like to me it
was like you know we already talked
about waiting on getting to the raid set
because we were good at today I will
laugh ourselves podcast you know we've
already talked about the rewards and how
we feel about them and it's like I don't
know how much longer you go with it
let's put it this way if this the next
state of the game that they do you don't
say and the numbers still reflect these
low completion counts I gotta change it
a little bit I gotta change something at
least the ease of entry that's one thing
Bungie learn like remember when black
armory came out right and they were like
yo what's going on the onboarding so
it's like something something has to be
tweaked that's what my gut is telling me
cuz this is too low it's too low II like
it's just my gut but wait what do you
feel are you feeling they need to stick
to their guns you feeling where you
where you at I'm probably where you are
I mean PC will have an advantage every
time because you just have more pinpoint
accuracy you're not trying to man just
like thumbs fix you have a mouse have
more just dexterity between those two
that's why more and more people on PC
versus controller even in a PvP
situation 9 out of you know nine point
nine out of 10 people will tell you
mouse a keyboard
we'll be will beat controller more often
than not so that's one of those words
tough to say it's a different platform
mm-hmm but I mean shout out to Bungie to
basically make an array that you that
seems to be having tested well enough
that you can do it on both yes like
that's one of those two where do you
need to hit this little thing our big
giant bosses with head boxes like
mechanics ups and downs but they've at
least managed to keep it doable on all
easier on PC might be a thing but I
don't feel like people have had this
complaint about the destiny raids ever
and this one seems to be a different
thing so this robot yeah this reminds me
of first encounter um black arm remember
how community was passed we like y'all
we can't even do not we not even doing a
damage like this just too high like
what's going on and then Bungie to their
credit what was it like would you say it
was how fast you remember that uh that
tweak to vault number one of black
armory would you say was a few hours six
hours the community was like this is
ridiculous we can't do it and like I'm
seeing um and massive it just drawing
this line in ass like nah fam you've got
to get good the other issue that a lot
of people are now saying shout out to em
- cos I'm not as well-versed on the game
builds yes but are required to do this
there's one build and it's DPS and
that's it that's it there's not much on
mechanics or healing it is just a DPS
check and that is more it than most like
there's communication there's mechanics
and those pieces and look the only sets
that you can actually beat it like if
somebody went in there with like a you
know ability said or something like that
that matter like the matter who did it
or full DPS builds most of the time that
was the success and that's what more
people who spent time be like hey you're
I'm gonna be the DPS guys we're gonna be
these okay we're gonna have a couple
people that are gonna be mostly
abilities for healing but if you were
like not doing what like if you were one
of those and you grind in hours and
hours and hours to build this perfect
set then that sets now useless because
the
PS is the only way to beat this thing
mostly it seems he is the bigger picture
this is where Bungie shows superiority
is that this is what they have to learn
if you're gonna do that
DPS thing you can't have the whole rig
you got to have certain encounters that
require a certain build so that
everybody has a role and then it's a
more efficient more effective overall
experience to have a pure DPS thing it's
like you know I'm saying and then you
know there was no prep for the community
to know what if like you said like what
if we just built this completely other
bill you're having fun you're doing your
thing and then you start raiding it's
useless it's useless and you have no
encounter to help that build have any
success in the rain that is a design
issue that means you showing your
inexperience with these raids and you
will have to take this feedback just you
know like I say I'm gonna I'm gonna it's
their first one right not gonna get
crazy it's their first one but they've
got to now be receptive to feedback and
listen otherwise then you start doing
decline and we started doing handsome
stuff we don't want to add some stuff we
don't like playing bases doing this we
want to stay here or we want to do this
so yeah please massive don't get too
crazy provided the armed player base you
know I'm saying like isn't completing it
still they're still not you gotta do
something
got to change it sorry if you guys hear
noise in the background I don't know if
you can it's a vacuum it's light like
something vacuum in a Cell okay sorry
about that hopefully I didn't soon yeah
that's kind of one of those things and
that's like shout out to Bungie for
having that like want the magical
balance line and that's not an easy
thing to do because I mean there's a lot
of testing that goes into these things
and they've learned a lot over the
course of doing what they've done so I
mean that's one of those things like
they've done well to listen to the
community to not release the 5:15
if gear sets were drop-in but generally
like your difficulty needs to be in
fairness or as you said like it can't
just all be about DPS and that's like a
hard piece to learn so
it did sound cool on some of the
mechanics I know like I kind of watched
em test the video kind of explain in the
fights and things like that I was
watching some of the first day one races
and things all of those pieces were cool
yeah but if it's just a bit too much for
like 99.999% of people you're gonna
exclude a lot when you already feel like
you waited too long to almost release it
that's kind of the other issue it's like
you have to at this point now help with
the onboarding into the raid if you've
already waited this long for people that
fell off to be like oh crap this is even
too hard I don't have the perfect set
well I'm not gonna go try it
you're not helping bring people back to
the new content you dropped which is a
big deal or supposed to be at least
you've nailed it it's it's literally on
board it you want people to at least
attempt you want people to what they are
attempting but you want people to be
able to get past the first encounter
you're they're like come on like you
really you want them to get P sub state
and then you can crank it up you know
I'm saying that's fine but if they're
not getting past first counters and
second encounters there's no desire to
want to continue that and they have to
be careful you know say they got it they
have to be careful so we'll see I'm very
curious to see next state of the game
where they are with things which should
be like next Wednesday or next Thursday
and C response yeah so yeah I just
wanted to touch on that one just because
that didn't will be seems to be a point
of contention right now so we will see
what happens there
but all in all hey it's shut up for a
second okay shout out to that car begin
clean yeah keep the house clean we have
a lot to look forward to next week we'll
open a few more eyes upon the changes to
the sandbox which will be really cool
and seriously
[Music]
its back oh it's not that bad bro I can
hear it through my headset you can hear
but for us is like yeah seriously though
like um because we haven't talked about
the redacted stuff the six player match
main activity that we don't even know if
is going to launch in the beginning or
if that
gonna be another week later what else is
redacted like is there an exotic quest
is there hidden things is there another
whisper is there another zero hours
there yet what else is in this season
like we don't even know know there's an
exotic quest for everybody on the
roadmap we know that nice we don't know
any of the other redacted stuff like
there could be quite a bit more I'm
hoping that like I said I mean I've
always felt I mean Australian drift as
you said trip
but I felt positive about digit rip this
is the one that I'm like you know what a
raids coming back looks like a company
and a lot of secret stuff getting exotic
you know I feel a little better you know
we'll see how it goes we see a guy I
mean everybody in drifter but uh you
know could drift I got him after really
assessing just wasn't strong enough for
me actually like actually dis actually
like like army better as a whole as
crazy as that sounds I like the gameplay
loop the only thing black armor II
didn't have I think drifter yes has lore
behind it and that's what kind of saves
it make it's cool but if you don't
really like gambit crime is it like
stone in the same boat you told me about
stone like he don't really care for is
he like a me prime probably not I don't
even know if a lot of people people are
torn on gambit verse game at prime to us
a little would say that's what's up man
had to argue with Cheryl you're sorry
back oh well oh yeah I mean you know I I
struggle with it's something about the
gameplay loop of armory that I really
did enjoy weird crying out for those
roles right ground and out for those
weapons I think it was cool yeah Joe
tune your head you know I'm saying you
had is it Nami last front it was just
cool things to just continue to play to
grind for and that ultimately is what
destiny about they just need to throw
more and more if they through look good
more in in armory it because so that's
why I'm hoping that opulence is the
sweet spot it's a good gameplay loop and
I think Calais week I feel confident
that go get a little you know I'm hoping
man I'll be a positive
so yeah definitely guys tune in next
week we'll have even more to talk about
sandbox changes pinnacles will be a
discussion I'm gonna finish up my Lotus
grind whoa cop man know what hip-hop 10
precision hand cannon kills to go ten
and it's my oops sorry ten and it's mine
I want to pull them up my Asus speak I
got to get down with you see that's the
gun nose I heard it was like alright I'm
living on it I got you know what it is e
I have this one last thing I look I got
this bad habit of having an ego with the
banner right so what I always happens to
me is when I light it like when I see
everybody knows is something else I
gotta be different I gotta I gotta I
gotta try and break the meta cuz I'm
better that you're not better than the
average of every single high level Blair
I go live in the meta house it's like
everybody got the same outfit I gotta be
fresh but you just pulled out of the
laundry doesn't look as good as that
pepper but found you got you got nothing
man you got to step in with what they're
using it looks too good out of there
they gotta think there's a reason you
know what it is though I mean it's a
it's a it's like ace is not the same a
console pc it's I think that's radar man
look down sigh trade off that is too
huge because you know where people are
anything I got it yeah you really did
I'm I got dust it off and infuse it and
stop playing around
that's what it is so yeah I don't know
if I'm gonna go for mountaintop but man
I hear some people on DPS if you go
mountain top with like a barricade or
lewd action well like mountain top is
powerful I hear I've seen people like
going through zero hour with it and
stuff in videos so really mountaintop
recluse and like thunder Lord for
example I've seen some people playing a
crazy build like that so like mm I mean
granted that's so be near innate
launcher kills and some of them like I'm
slowly working on the grenade launcher
peed use of like militias birthright or
whatever the kinetic one just to get
some general use look the double kills
the multi kills and then the
three without dying I don't know how
many you need on those but man that is I
have zero percent on both of those and
I've been playing a lot of comple that
is gonna be a whole different I'm gonna
be useless to my team when I go for that
yeah let me see how low I can get that
glory score back down can I get it down
to zero cuz it might happen so yeah
it'll Italy camp about a heavy all right
guys well it's been awesome today I
think we're gonna let this man get some
sleep
you guys this is will be on audio audio
I'll try and get a little since I don't
have the issue today I'm actually
recording it audio should go up pretty
quick and then I'll post this up my
video tomorrow I think it'll be yours
today for iron Lords podcast and yeah
you guys can catch that one but catch
the audio guys and listen there we're
trying to help grow that one so Spotify
iTunes Google podcast and like six
others there's a whole bunch of places
you can find the auto version so take it
with you on the road listen to all you
work because I know YouTube's not always
as as data friendly for some so thank
you all very much
it's been awesome this morning tell him
what you got going on this week sir yeah
man I love podcast you already know we
got a big one we got a big one this
Sunday is the prediction series part two
last week part 1 was a fan the arocs
gaming stealth and all the crew that
came through a man these guys showed
tremendous love if you missed that one
that one's on the Nintendo e3 prediction
series that's last week check that out
on our podcast YouTube channel but this
week it's all about Sony so we got some
Sony representation in the building they
have a man j-dub city we're gonna have
broken games HD and I believe we are
going to have the silver sky and J bar
is so we're gonna have some strong so
many support just hold on to got there
yeah we got four guests great panel
we're gonna talk about the future of
Sony everything that's going on in the
industry with them the outlook for
PlayStation 5 please check that out and
of course when I'm gonna podcast you
already know we've got some other good
content please check out Kings that's
some great kinetic statues up right now
tremendous Iron Man please check that I
was really nice he's got tag going on
and um as you already know last where
you can find later after you didn't
watch it live you can catch it later
also on IL p thanks my man he puts it up
shout out there you know saying but um
you
it's gonna be a good show so please
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
check it out and also last plug I will
put in Lords of gaming down that y'all
please check us out I'll put those I put
those two arms up early in the morning
on Fridays my little synopsis of what's
the you know the key points and stuff
that we end up talking about here and
yeah man really really cool stuff so
appreciate the love Lords of gaming
dotnet and that's what I got man I got a
shout out guys
got a secret guest scheduled for June
28th we got him potentially pending on
the book so you guys to look forward to
that show so June 28th see if you want
to catch that one live that will be cool
working another guest so trying to get
some other people in here to mix it up
with us because while we have two
opinions the more the merrier sometimes
especially in Disney Minds so trying to
get a few more people to pass through
with us guess they're honestly like
there was always awesome because we have
a lot of fun in here
but like getting that third opinion just
crazy so hey guests are a good thing so
I'm just not gonna reveal who it is
right now we'll let you know when we get
closer once it's all ironed in and sits
tell y'all check yo y'all gonna like
these guests yeah yeah you guys have
been awesome today chats been lit you
guys have been amazing I still feel
weird saying lit I'm too white I really
am there's certain words I just can't
say and like you can say make you weep
right over here it's true anyway but
thank you guys you guys are awesome so
that is it for this week of May 24th
tune in next week check out iron Lords
podcast the channels the youtubes
everything everywhere twitch Twitter all
those things so thank you guys very much
iron Lords podcast Lords of gaming net
and for this week episode 60 we made it
to 60 60 oh yeah for that this week it
has been the only last word